un palais de justice en sommeil et c'est
comme cela depuis une semaine au
tribunal de fort-de-france
les avocats poursuivre leur mobilisation
contre la réforme de la justice censée
désengorger les tribunaux et faire des
économies
plusieurs mesures vont à l'encontre des
libertés des justiciables selon les
avocats mécontents par exemple pour les
procédures simples rapides comme des
procédures de roquettes sur injonction
de payer
et bien maintenant on ne passera plus
devant un juge
on devra déposer sa demande sur une
plateforme numérique nationale des
petits litiges géré par ordinateur des
pensions réévalué par la caisse
d'allocations familiales
c'est le recul des avocats dans les
procédures d mesure rejetée par 90% des
avocats présents en assemblée générale
les audiences seront donc renvoyé faute
d'avocat sauf exception cas par cas
pourtant certains justiciables dont le
jugement est reportée comprennent le
mouvement ah non moi je suis contre ça
c'est mieux qu'hier les avocats c'est
mieux un ordre d'une machine peut pas
décider du sort des quelque 1 c'est moi
c'est inhumain
le gouvernement souhaite faire voter la
réforme avant la fin de l'année alors
les avocats tentent de peser de tout
leur poids dans les débats l'objectif
influencer la décision des
parlementaires qui vont valider la loure
il ne laisserons pas cette loi se voter
sans les amendements que nous avons
rédigé et que nous demandons à nos
sénateurs de portée nous allons nous
battre jusqu'au bout
des réunions sont organisées avec les
parlementaires martiniquais dans la
tente d'obtenir des garanties
la grève des avocats se poursuit
jusqu'au 6 décembre